lost for decades beneath the center of
naples italy the bourbon tunnel is an
underground time capsule of the city's
history
this system of tunnels and caverns was
originally conceived in the 1800s as an
escape tunnel by king ferdinand ii
connecting the royal palace to the
military barracks but the king died
before its completion
the tunnel was then abandoned until the
early 1930s when it was used as a
storage facility for impounded and
contraband vehicles
many of which are still there today
[Music]
during world war ii the tunnel changed
uses again this time becoming a military
hospital and bomb shelter
after the war it turned into a dumping
ground for rubble destroyed cars and
pro-fascist marble statues before it was
sealed and then forgotten
it was accidentally rediscovered in 2005
when government geologists were checking
the conditions of nearby quarries
now the galleria borbonica belongs to
the public who explore the eras before
them as they wander the ancient caverns
[Music]
you